Guten morgen linus.
Guten morgen tim.
Heute ist freitag der dreizehnte das ist schon umsatzsteuer voranmeldung gemacht.
Also es gibt ja so ein kleines problem mit der banking also was ich fragen wollte tim kannst dann können wir vielleicht jemand geld leihen.
Aux
Logbuch netz politik nummer dreihundert zwölf,
freitag dem dreizehnten dreizehnter september zweitausendneunzehn und wir sind schon wieder auf der bühne wie sollte es auch anders sein nämlich auf der,
was ist das ist nichts politik konferenz in berlin im roten salon und haben ganz viele tolle gäste wir sagen hallo schönen guten tag,
ja ich muss mal gucken was ich habe.
Reicht aber ich brauche den digital.
Reicht tja das ist äh schwierig weil wir.
Eigentlich zählt er ist ein gutes beispiel weil ich glaub ich muss gerade nachrechnen ungefähr ein zehner am tag,
nee noch nicht mal doch etwas über den zehner am tag habe ich verdient als ich bei netzwerk ob mein praktikum gemacht habe ja.
Ernsthaft wow.
Ich hab das nämlich gestern alles nochmal recherchiert weil markus reuter auch redakteur bei netzwerk,
schreib mir gestern ja linus hast du nicht hast du nicht peinliche bilder von früher,
markus und du in der redaktion und hatte ich.
Vor dir oder von euch beiden.
Aber aber die waren so peinlich die waren sogar mir zu peinlich,
deswegen gibt sie wahrscheinlich dann heute nicht in markus vortrag weil gleich gibt's ja noch die große abschluss gala und so und da werden dann noch peinliche bilder schon markus becker tal und mir gezeigt sende ich feier,
zweitausendzehn müsste das gewesen sein praktikant was ich leider nicht mehr gefunden habe ist meine meine bewerbung die hätte ich eigentlich die wahrscheinlich auch peinlich gewesen.
Wieso.
Falls ich durch bewerbungen schreiben es immer peinlich ja.
Keine ahnung ich habe noch nie eine.
Ich habe das aber ach jetzt weiß ich auch wieder wo das ist die bewerbung war nicht in dokumente sondern in reports stories welche natürlich in latex gemacht habe ich hätte ja gerade mal.
Du hast den link aufgeht hab einfach geschickt so hier ist meine bewerbung.
Geht hab damals schon.
Nein oder zwanzig zehn doch vielleicht.
Weiß ich nicht vielleicht schon weiß ich nicht aber ich habe auf jeden fall habe ich nicht meine bewerbung auf geht ab gerostet das war einfach immer schon,
aber man eigentlich geil gewesen die so einfach nur so mit 'nem make meine bewerbung finden sie unter clown make und dann irgendwie so erstmal fünfundvierzig gigabyte latex pakete installieren.
Und wenn sie das nicht kompliziert bekommen dann will ich bei ihnen auch überhaupt gar nicht erst anfangen,
man muss das nämlich umdrehen dieser test ja also ich meine man muss ja eigentlich immer von sich überzeugt sein wenn man sich irgendwo,
bewirbt und sagt so ja also selber schuld wenn ihr meine größe nicht erkennt so hier ist ein test damit ich mir auch sicher sein kann dass das passt,
denn es prüfe wer sich.
Sie haben sie haben sich ja bei mir beworben mit ihrem praktikum schauen wir mal ob ich das haben möchte.
Genau sie haben da ist sehr schön.
Was was was wieso wieso glauben sie denn dass dieses praktikum das richtige für mich,
wie stellen sie sich ihre zukunft wie stellen sie sich die unternehmen in fünfzehn jahren vorher herr becker.
Wo sehen sie mich in fünf jahren,
auf welcher ebene.
Und das war auf jeden fall gut,
dann hab ich nach sechs monaten praktikum glaube ich wurde ich befördert,
immerhin zum ersten festangestellten mitarbeitern weil netzwerk will man gar nicht meint ne,
mit so mit so groß katastrophalen fehlentscheidungen gestartet und trotz allem ist aus netzwerk da noch was gewonnen.
Das stimmt ich habe da auch mal ein bisschen in meinem katalog geblättert als,
eine gemeinsame bekannte von uns postete das jetzt ein auf spiegel online ein exklusives interview mit dem chef von politik punkt org ist und dann dachte ich mir so.
Andere meister war auf spieler.
Ich hatte damals den markus da war damals der einzige aber ihr habt uns.
Du hast ein chaos radio express.
Genau und zwar so richtig richtig früh früh da gab's das alles irgendwie auch erst ein paar monate ich hab's mir jetzt nicht nochmal angehört muss ich zugeben aber,
das war eigentlich ganz interessant so damals so diese sicht so ja ich hab da mal angefangen so ein bisschen bei netz politik zu bloggen macht ja sonst keiner,
mal gucken was passiert und ich würde sagen die rakete hat eigentlich ganz gut gezündet.
Das hat sehr gut gezündet.
Mit staatlicher unterstützung natürlich dann zwischendurch auch ich freue mich ja wenn wir endlich mal angeklagt werden dass wir auch mal so richtig.
Logbuch netzwerk vielleicht weniger als andere sachen aber da können wir auch noch.
Wir gehen einfach zugeschickt vor ja die kommen uns überhaupt nicht auf die schliche.
Weil wir wir beginnen unsere gedanken verbrechen ja in zwei tage wollen wir auch kürzlich vorgeworfen aber das äh.
Ja das ist aber nicht der einzige also es ist ja auch noch ein anderes,
verbrechen gerade bei tageslicht begangen worden wie ich die verabschiedung der richtige ps die zwei.
Also verabschiedung schon früher aber jetzt die umsetzung.
War aber alles bei tageslicht soweit ich das.
Alles bei tageslicht wobei man echt meinen muss die waren besoffen im dunkeln als die das getan haben,
payment services direction zwei ja soll regeln wie banken untereinander irgendwie standardmäßig kommunizieren und zwingt oder nicht untereinander sondern mit dritt anbieter,
und zwingt banken jetzt zum open banking sie müssen eine bereitstellen denkt man sich super iphone war immer gut.
Total gut open auch ne also.
Zum beispiel auch ein radler meeting auf meiner banking haben ne dass man nicht zu schnell geld ausgibt,
und,
aber stellt sich raus so wirklich als kunde kriegst du nicht unbedingt eine sondern das ganze,
regelt eigentlich den zugriff sogenannter fintech,
das sind so,
glorreiche vertreter der zunft sie wie sofortüberweisung sofortüberweisung gehört ja das warum beworben wurde das noch nicht verboten,
weil die die finanz daten von allen haben und sich niemand mehr an die rand traut weil das was sie machen kann ja eigentlich überhaupt nicht zulässig sein ja um um sowas irgendwie ab zu also sofort überweisung geb dir quasi eure,
konto zugangsdaten dann gucken sie sich ein bisschen drei monate transaktionen an und sagen ja hier ist noch was drauf oder nicht gibt meine tante dann füllen wir eine überweisung für dich aus was eigentlich verboten ist,
ja also so was zu tun also wenn ich sage geht mal die zugangsdaten zu eurem konto und gib mal an,
dann krieg ich ärger aber sofortüberweisung konnte es machen würden wie gesagt okay so was ist irgendwie mist zeigt zumindest ein druck der,
besseren zugang und irgendwie sortierten zugang zu bankkonten haben sollten weiß man nicht genau ob das so sinnvoll ist oder nicht.
Das ist ja vor allem es ist ja vor allem ein,
ein grandioses scheitern eigentlich einer einer einer geschichte die die hätte so schön werden können meine als.
Davon handelt unser podcast regelmäßig.
Ich weiß dauerthema als als du dich wahrscheinlich noch mehr mit plüschtiere herumgeschlagen hast,
ja ja ich muss ja auch die unterschiede mal ein bisschen,
so sieht's aus aber das war wirklich eine verheißung ich bin ja eigentlich im muss sagen im nachgang die post hat zwar viel prügel bezogen so generell für x,
aber an sich war die idee ja gar nicht so scheiße und vor allem das mit dem online-banking das hat ja mindestens genauso schnell eingeschlagen wie porno,
und das ist eigentlich eine gute sache gewesen und wir haben uns so ein bisschen dran gewöhnt dass man ja in irgendeiner form programmatisch na so irgendwie an seinem konto rankommt und ich bin immer wieder schockiert wenn ich sehe dass es in anderen ländern ja überhaupt keinerlei realität darstellt.
Was auch gar nicht so gut ist wie sich zeigt weil jetzt denken sich so naja also wenn die anderen länder das nicht hinkriegen dann kann man das ja eigentlich auch mal zurückfahren,
dann dringend halt diese auszahlung dienstleister da mit ins feld versuchen irgendwie das abzubilden was die banken in ihren user interface und so weiter nicht so richtig hinbekommen haben
also erstmal zwei schon mal so eine überweisung mal schnell macht oder irgendwie sowas,
und jetzt haben wir halt diese neue detektive die schlicht dazu führt dass zwar,
aufgestellt werden wo man erstmal denkt so geil,
aber diese abi sind halt eigentlich nur für diese anderen unternehmen und über die kunden steht soweit ich das verstanden habe in dieser ganzen detektive,
nicht und noch schlimmer einzige banken meinen jetzt so na ja also wenn jetzt diese ganzen zwischen heinis dazwischen kommen und irgendwie fancy fünf null webseiten aufsetzen mit dem man alles irgendwie kontrollieren kann.
Dann machen wir die.
Dann machen wir halt das ist eher so defiziten arbeiten nur so nervös und so und es ist alles viel zu teuer dann machen wir das einfach zu
ne wir machen nur noch diese eine abi und das reicht schon und dann sitzt man an jetzt irgendwie so als halbwegs entwickelt der finanznot und denkt sich so geil volle kontrolle über alles und dann kommt zu dieser dreizehnte
freitag der dreizehnte stopp und wir machen jetzt kriegt auf einmal tannen meldung um die ohren geworfen für nix und wieder nichts,
ergebnis dass irgendwie unsere.
Holen sei der zum macht ihr online-banking.
Mach dir jemand online-banking.
Wer macht kein online-banking alle anderen machen online-banking heute schon probiert.
Probieren.
Mach dir das über webseiten oder so lieber mit händen.
Die hatten alle keine zeit.
Wer macht das über webseiten wer macht online-banking.
Naja viele.
Das sind viele.
Ja ich mach das nicht.
Und da habt ihr habt ihr nur ein konto oder oder ist da einfach nicht so viel geld drauf oder wie könnt ihr euch das leisten weil das ist ja wirklich also dass das welcher katastrophe also online-banking meine webseite mache ich genau,
um das passwort zu ändern oder so aber über eine webseite also ich finde sowieso webseite ist einfach.
Und lastschrift wieder zurückgehen lassen ja also,
das ist immer wieder wie singulärer wir da in unserer attitüde.
Ja wir sind halt also online-banking lass mich das euch erklären bis bis heute,
oder gestern konnte man online-banking mit einer app machen mit einer application auf eurem computer die container transaktion starten vielleicht verschlüsselt gespeichert ihr konntet auf mehrere konnten gleichzeitig zugreifen und,
konnte dann schön mit seinem hardware security talking also mit der liste auf papier,
wunderschönes sicherheitskonzept konnte man transaktionen auslösen und,
und diese transaktionen zu man brauchte man wenn man eine transaktion durchführt jetzt neuerdings haben sich banken offenbar entschieden dass das abholen eures der das konto standes auch eine transaktion ist,
und wenn ich jetzt meine online-banking app aufmache in der,
keine ahnung vier fünf kunden sind dann muss ich vier fünf tanz eingeben,
wäre in ordnung wenn man die app nur einmal öffnet ja jetzt sagt sie ist die app aber so eingestellt dass sie alle zwei minuten einfach die neuen umsätze holt ja weil das geld kommt okay jetzt wisst ihr erkennt ihr mich und,
dann will die wieder sechs tanz haben so jetzt aber der gag.
Mit sechs verschiedenen apps und.
Sechs verschiedene woher kommt jetzt die tannen,
ja oder guck mal irgendwie so gibt's bestimmte konnten wo ich jetzt selten transaktionen mache oder dicke scheiße,
bei dem konnte hab ich eigentlich nie vorgesehen das geld nochmal auszugeben wie komme ich denn jetzt an so eine tan,
da gibt's irgendeine app die man mal vor jahren installiert hat und diese app ist im prinzip wie so eine kita app also eine app auf eurem handy soll euch dann eine transaktion zimmer.
Diese app ist aber zwangsweise mit einem passwort geschützt und natürlich darf das nicht das welche passwort sein wie der zugang so viel wusste ich also habe ich jetzt irgendeine app mit irgendeinem passwort irgendwann einmal geschützt hätte ich ein passwort noch gewusst hätte ich mit dieser app meine transaktionen zu bekommen um auf mein konto zugreifen,
die das war aber jetzt nicht mehr möglich und dann habe ich irgendwie überlegt ok was mache ich denn jetzt jetzt kann ich nicht mehr lesen auf dieses konto zugreifen,
und ne also nur um mein kontostand abzuholen bei euch also jetzt passwort passwort für diese app dann den zweiten faktor den diese app generiert und dann kann ich einmal mein kontostand erfahren beziehungsweise transaktionen raus,
ist auf jeden fall schon mal insofern gut als dass man sicher stehen kann dass irgendwelche sofortüberweisung spinner auf jeden fall nicht mehr auf mein konto zugreifen können so viel punkte gebe ich den.
Aber es hat jemand diese app entwickelt und diese gesamte,
kommunikation zu schnell von der bank und so weiter dann hab ich gesagt ok,
candy code nicht mehr ich habe den jetzt fünf mal falsch eingegeben ist das geld jetzt weg oder hab ich noch eine chance das nochmal wieder zu bekommen habe ich bei der bank angerufen sagen ja lassen sie sich doch einfach neuen professionalisierung code für die app schicken hab ich gesagt ist in ordnung machen wie kriege ich,
ja per sms ich habe immer per sms meine tanz bekommen warum kriege ich die nicht einfach weiterhin ja weil das unsicher ist,
ich sag guter mann sie schicken dir jetzt am ende nicht eine tanz sondern alle tanz die ich im leben nochmal generieren könnte über diese sms was machen wir hier also verstehen sie das,
ja ja hat er wohl verstanden ich würde also jetzt eine sms bekommen und dann das war die erste bank,
ähm wie gesagt ich habe da mit mir ich habe mich auf mehrere eingelassen ne zweite bank sagt geben sie bitte ihre tanne ein gibt's getan ein sage die,
terror.
Ja okay dann hab ich versucht nicht irgendwie über diese web interface einzuloggen ich wollte ja wenigstens wissen ob ich noch geld habe ich wusste nicht ob es mir leisten kann heute abend noch hierher zu fahren mit der u-bahn ja und dann,
guck ich da rein ja dreimal code falsch eingegeben geh weg,
ja war ich also aus meinem online-banking bei dieser bank ausgeschlossen das ist die bank die ich gebraucht hätte um meine umsatzsteuer voranmeldung zu machen ja ging also auch nicht,
dann hab ich an den hersteller der app also meiner online-banking app geschrieben und sagt ja hier pipapo bank und so alles irgendwie schlecht,
schreibt mir zurück der finde beziehungsweise der sowieso bank,
verhält sich seit der gestrigen umstellung nicht mehr spezifikationen konfort die signifikante sind vom server wie folgt durch nummeriert,
eins zwei drei sms fünf sechs sieben,
b s acht die programmierer bei der sowieso bank haben sich bei der nummer vier verzählt,
deswegen funktioniert es nicht hoffentlich verzeihen sie sich wenigstens nicht beim geld.
Ja mit mit mit der bank hatte ich auch spaß beim das geile ist ja.
Sehr gut die hattest du mir auch empfohlen tim genauso genauso wie dieses schöne software ja,
so jetzt sitze ich hier.
Fohlen mit großen anführungsstrichen ja und vor allem das geile ist ja dass sie,
die software hatte gar keine chance darauf zu reagieren die wusste sozusagen überhaupt nichts von ihrem glück das jetzt irgendwie tank kommt weil das nicht richtig signalisiert wird trotzdem hat das ding ja beim anrufen das dürfte vielleicht auch gemerkt haben,
einen parallel während des vergeblich versucht hat das programm darauf zuzugreifen kam parallel die ganzen tanz per sms ja man macht irgendwie dreimal reloaded und fragt sich was irgendwie fase ist,
irgendwann denkst dir so okay dann mache ich mich da vielleicht mal auf der webseite ein.
Neben dirk klingelt die ganze zeit das handy und ich muss mich hier konzentrieren es geht um mein ganzes geld.
Ruf ich mir da heute leider müssen ja sie haben sich dreimal haben sie tanzt falsch eingegeben haben wir jetzt den zugang gesperrt,
die muss man doch einfach wirklich mit dem feuchten mob einfach links und rechts bis.
Aber es geht noch weiter.
Noch weiter.
Ja dann hab ich dann hab ich also bei dieser anderen bank wo wo ich per sms den kompletten zweiten faktor wiederherstellen konnte was alles sinnlos machen kann man das nicht machen,
wir können nur den initialen zieht für alle zweiten faktoren sonst geben aber ihr könnt auch nicht den zweiten faktor per sms abbilden ja also jeder jeder kann jetzt einfach mehr oder weniger,
ganz schlimm ja ganz ganz ganz schlimm da muss wie ich schon sagte diese tanne app muss jetzt mit einem pascal gesichert werden was wirklich sehr ärgerlich ist,
weil jetzt halte ich diese unterschiedlichen tanne apps die heißen natürlich dann auch irgendwie wie heißt du dies,
go
wer will wer wünscht sich nicht eine tante kohle zum kaffee und,
brauchst du auch für jeden kaffee eine weil jeder jedes konto abrufen ist eine transaktion so dann musste dann hast du aber noch die normale banking-app von der von der bank auch noch da das heißt du kannst jetzt nicht irgendwie du sitzt auf dem handy sagt okay,
xy bank dann suchst du nach der x y bank dann geht aber die banking-app auf und nicht die app weil die tanne app heißt irgendwie äh nächstes level zweitausend,
sowieso bank secure so und dann ok jetzt hatte die eine app halt anforderungen an einen code und ich hab überlegt okay.
Wie komme ich jetzt damit zurecht hier überall für meinen zweiten faktor kurz vergeben das schöne an dem zweiten faktor war ja dass er eben nicht ein passwort ist das ist ja die idee des zweiten faktoren ein haben ein sein ein wissen oder so naja,
also habe ich gesagt na ja ok ich vergebe jetzt hier ein pin versucht mit den zu merken ja nächste app.
Sag ich bin ja okay was nochmal jetzt ne habe ich über,
also wenn ich jetzt den gleich nehme dann muss ich mir nur einen merken wohl wissen dass sich da jetzt wahrscheinlich so gegen das verstoße was ich die ganze zeit versuche anderen leuten beizubringen habe ich gedacht um jetzt mal wenigstens heute,
meine kontostand zu erfahren.
So fängt es immer an.
Um zu wissen ob ich hier nur mal hinfahren kann habe ich gesagt gibt's den gleichen peter sagt er du brauchst noch ein sonderzeichen und buchstaben habe ich gesagt okay kein thema machen wir sonderzeichen und buchstaben sonderzeichen,
in die andere app rein und ich sage ich möchte bitte mein bin ändern und ich werde mich jetzt an seiner zeit buchstabe hinzufügen sagt die andere nur zahlen mein.
Was für was heißt das ich meine somit treibt das jetzt die menschen dazu dass sie am ende in ihr in ihrer cloud oder oder,
oder ein foto in ihrem in ihrem profil haben als favorit oder so wo sind die unterschiedlichen codes haben um an ihren zweiten faktor zu kommen garantiert wenn die leute das irgendwo auf ihren telefon speichern das heißt die leute verlieren jetzt ihr telefon,
und es ist alles ganz fürchterlich also,
am ende wird das nicht sicherer machen sondern so unbenutzt bare sicherheit treibt die leute,
am ende dazu was weiß ich die pins in den in den schoner von ihrem telefon rein zu ritzen weil oder oder ins display mit dem mit dem spitzen stein oder so aber dass sie auf jeden fall nicht,
sicherer sind sondern einfach keinen zugang zu ihrem geld haben also ich gehe gleich eine mütze rum vielleicht könnt ihr mir aushelfen.
Sollte irgendein frustrierte mitarbeiter aus der banking industrie hier zuhören,
bitte leute echt einloggen mit tannen ich weiß nicht wer euch den vogel in den kopf gesetzt hat wenn es unbedingt sein muss und ich hab ein gewisses kleines minimales verständnis dafür,
in so webseiten zu machen ja.
Webseiten hab ich kein verständnis für die müssen alle so die müssen als erstes weg.
Die webseite müssen komplett weg aber solange es noch gibt wenn man sich da einloggt meinetwegen das einloggen da auch noch mit nathan gehe ich mit weil das mache ich ja auch nicht.
Du hast doch kein gewinn dadurch ach so.
Will doch nur meine ruhe ich möchte aber einfach nur wenn ich eine wenn ich ein programm benutze was irgendwie über eine app peters ab fragt ja meinetwegen einmal beim einrichten irgendwie so eine tanne,
wenn es glücklich macht aber dann bitte doch erstmal für das nächste jahr nicht mehr.
Die haben noch was wir haben noch was schöneres gehabt bei dieser eine app die ich dann zum laufen bekommen habe dadurch dass sie mir einfach den zieht wieder per sms geschickt haben und weil das alles so unsinnig war.
Wie viele apps was jetzt installiert allein irgendwie innerhalb eines tages.
Einige hatte ich ja schon installiert deswegen hatte ich die codes vergessen voraus,
gesehen voraus gedacht,
und ne es gibt noch eine achte die ist jetzt nicht in diesem ordner also irgendwie acht apps oder so,
und ich werde euch die eine aufmache kommt sofort willkommen geben sie ihre passiert das geht alles jetzt so weiter ich bin da jetzt gefangen und genau diese eine,
sms tanja dann wird immer gesagt ok dann kann man abfangen und da gibt's diese sims attacken das stimmt alles das ist richtig aber die hatten wenigstens ein,
ein aspekt richtig das sind nämlich zu der tanne dazu gesagt haben diese tan ist für folgende transaktion nämlich du möchtest zehntausend euro auf die seychellen überweisen hier ist die tante,
und wenn man das dann sieht und sagt jo genau zehntausend euro auf die seychellen oder ne ich wollte drei euro achtzig nach mallorca überweisen,
dann kann man da quasi nochmal kontrollieren was man gerade freigibt in dieser anderen app musstest du quasi einen knopf drücken damit du eine tannen generierst,
was in meiner lesart bedeutet masse hat das handy kein empfang,
kannst du keine tanz generieren es ist alles ihr habt alles kaputt gemacht das hat alles funktioniert,
es hat alles funktioniert mal früher also vorgestern.
Ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt nicht so recht vorstellen dass das die hotlines nicht gerade brennen in deutschland also das ist die leute die da arbeiten sind bestimmt schon voll frustriert.
Bei der einwanderung die sagte dass,
ja die psd zwei haben wir uns ja nicht ausgedacht und eure lobbyisten haben sich ausgedacht und außerdem bei den anderen apps funktioniert's nur bei euch nicht also erzähl mir nichts ja also sie hätten das jetzt schon
also ich bräuchte jetzt nicht ungefähr so frech zu werden wie alle anderen die heute abend.
Die war bestimmt noch viel frecher ja es ist schlimm na ja.
Aber das das hat die wenn ihr euch wenn ihr euch fragt was hat die eu jemals für uns getan ja sie hat jetzt eine payment services direction gebaut jetzt die banken dazu bringt genau nicht offene standards zu machen jeder denkt sich irgend eigenen schwachsinn aus,
und wir kommen nicht mehr kommen nicht mehr in unsere konten und wenn das so weitergeht weiß ich auch nicht,
also dann muss ich irgendwie geld weiterleitungen machen auf auf irgendeinen irgendein land wo die psd zwei nicht gilt gibt's hier der in der ersten reihe dessen namen ich nicht weiß ob ich denn hier ins mikrofon sagen darf gibt's gilt die psd zwei null in europa,
also für das geld was ich auf den inseln habe.
Insel.
Dann weiß man wenigstens warum die leute ihr geld auf die inseln schicken ja.
Ja dinos weißt du was.
Ja es gibt eine gute nachricht.
Die europäische gesetzgebung funktioniert offensichtlich nicht da muss man das in deutschland machen dann,
weißt du dann läuft das auch einfach da ist die erfahrung da da ist das handwerk einfach über jahrhunderte gepflegt worden und dann läuft es einfach.
So ein leistungsschutzrecht das deutsche leistungsschutzrecht ist unwirksam.
Wegen eines form fehlers.
Also es gab irgendwie es gab jetzt offenbar irgendwie ein eine auseinandersetzung zwischen der,
vw media glaube ich und google weil die folge media quasi auf basis des leistungsschutzrecht ist jetzt geld von google erpressen wollte und dann hat,
das zuständige deutsche gericht den europäischen gerichtshof gefragt hat gesagt sag mal wir haben uns erstmal angeschaut ist dieses deutsche leistungsschutzrecht überhaupt gültig,
und stellt sich raus nein denn das deutsche leistungsschutzrecht ist eine technische vorschrift im sinne der richtlinie achtundneunzig dreiundvierzig ihr kennt sie und ähm,
deswegen hätte sie als solche der kommission übermittelt werden müssen der europäische kommission,
um in einem anwendungsfälle,
deswegen ist das deutsche leistungsschutzrecht eigentlich aufgrund eines vorm fehlers,
unwirksam wer hätte das gedacht dass wir das noch loswerden.
Ja es ist toll ich meine gefühlt weiß ich gar nicht meine das ding läuft ja jetzt auf europäischer ebene jetzt ohnehin weiter von daher sind wir noch nicht so richtig los,
aber damit gab's das zumindest offiziell nicht bisher hat ja auch bisher noch nichts gebracht.
Hätte nur an die an die an die kommission übermittelt werden müssen was auch immer dieses übermitteln,
bedeutet aber man muss der entwurf einer technischen vorschrift ist der kommission vorab zu übermitteln,
ist dies nicht geschehen kann ein einzelner deren un anwendbarkeit geltend machen also kannst du sagen was du willst aber google hat wahrscheinlich echt ganz gute anwälte dass die.
Vielleicht haben sie ja auch übermittelt aber sie haben vergessen die talheim zu geben.
Also das ist schon mal das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Diese transaktion konnte leider nicht abgeschlossen werden tut mir leid.
Jedenfalls wird das jetzt es wird nicht lange dauern dass wir dann das leistungsschutzrecht jetzt nochmal wieder über die kriegen aber immerhin.
Immerhin.
Das war die gute nachricht diese woche übrigens ne es kommt noch eine es gibt noch eine gute,
sie bei uns im raum jetzt geht's erstmal schlechte nachricht.
Ja weil mein iphone ist kaputt.
Das habe ich schon in der friedhof gehört wie lange ich wollte immer kurz auf toilette willst das jetzt kurz erzählen nochmal oder funktioniert das nicht jetzt schon wieder deine.
Ich weiß nicht da ist irgendwas drin irgendwas irgendwas äh kommt manchmal und sagt ich darf nicht mit meinem telefon arbeiten vielleicht bin ich gehackt worden ich bin keine hure.
Du bist aber noch gar keine das war doch apples ausrede dafür.
Aber ich bin august vielleicht reicht das ja auch schon.
Was ist was ist passiert tatsächlich ein größeres problem,
das forscher von google also von google project zero haben,
eine webseite festgestellt die sich in diesem internet befunden hat die,
tatsächlich die eigenschaft hatte dass man sie nur besuchen brauchte,
und allein der besuch dieser website hat ausgereicht um das iphone nachhaltig mit schadstoff fair zu infizieren infiziert ist hier der falsche begriff also es hat eine schadstoffe zum laufen gebracht,
die dann weiter lief und euer telefon ausspioniert hat bis zu dem zeitpunkt wo man es neu gestartet hat also es war keine infektion infektion hätte bedeutet,
die schadstoffe hat irgendwie per systems und bei einem neustart des telefons funktioniert sie weiter das war nicht der fall,
aber so remote code situation mit einem besuch einer website,
so viel schlimmer geht's eigentlich nicht das wäre jetzt das einzige was noch,
gewesen wäre hätte noch nicht mal meine webseite besuchen müssen sowas hat man selten,
und das war ja schon relativ dramatisch eigentlich fühlte mich bedroht.
Du fühlst dich bedroht ja ich dachte mir auch so wenn er wirklich jetzt tatsächlich zwei jahre lang irgendwas im netz rum damit was in der lage wäre massenhaft
iphones
schnorchel und man kriegt das nicht mit das ist schon ein ziemlich dicker fall allerdings hat apple das auch hat sich ein paar tage später geäußert und meint war alles gar nicht so schlimm weil,
sind ja nur die figuren die da angegriffen wurden sehr schön,
teil in dieser meldung ist dass das wort china dort nicht fällt.
Sie haben das sehr schön also sehr sehr wenig elegant zum ausdruck gebracht als allererstes war diese fortgeschrittene sophie sehr eng fokussiert und nicht,
einfach breit in in alle richtungen wie google ist beschrieben hat also es war eine website wer sie besucht hat wurde gehackt ja das halte ich für eine relativ breite,
fokussierung des angriff strahl ist aber apple sagt naja der angriff richtete sich ja nur der angriff fand nur über weniger als,
ein dutzend webseiten statt die sich allesamt,
inhalte für die figuren bereit gestellt haben also mit anderen worten es verstanden keine gefahr für die bevölkerung nur für euren,
außerdem dann kommt noch der standards außerdem regal of the state of the also unabhängig davon wie groß dieser angriff jetzt wirklich war nehmen wir,
die sicherheit unserer nutzer aller nutzer extrem ernst ja völlig unbedingt die beste reaktion von apple da also das war.
Wieso was hätten sie deiner meinung nach sagen soll.
Sagen so ey das ist sehr einfach sagen sollen wir haben schwachstellen gehabt die wurde über jahre ausgenutzt,
in einem gezielten angriff von einem staat gegen eine minderheit und das geht ja mal gar nicht.
Dann hätten sie vielleicht china sagen müssen wussten sie.
Kann man sagen ja kann man.
Ja das weiß ja wie schwierig das so und daneben die china ihr ganzen scheiß produzieren lassen.
Ja also mit mit anderen worten der satz saskia es ging um den haben die eher geschrieben damit die chinese sich nicht aufregend.
Ne das muss ich sagen finde ich 'ne interessante formulierung sie hätten ja auch von irgendwelchen minderheiten sprechen können aber sie haben sich schon relativ konkret benannt und damit weiß ja eigentlich auch jeder wo es herkommt,
oder meint zumindest jeder zu glauben zu wissen wo es herkommt.
Also es ist eine mittel schwere katastrophe solche schwachstellen über längere zeit zu haben und,
ändert jetzt für die sicherheit der plattform nichts dass sie bis offenbar der einzige bisher bekannte fall wo sie ausgenutzt wurden halt dann ausgerechnet eine staatlich verfolgte minderheit betrifft.
Deine.
Nichts was du als hersteller dieser geräte irgendwie als beschwichtigen des argument anbringen kannst,
so ja war eine schwachstelle ja wurde über jahre ausgenutzt aber nur durch nur zu staatliche verfolgung von minderheiten ja.
Sonst nichts.
Sonst nichts also,
wir als weiße privilegierte brauchen ist ja keine sorgen zu machen die kommen das ist das geht so nicht.
Also sollte sich aber jemand äh unter in unserer führerschaft als hure fühlen ja also rein solidarisch immerhin sind die schwachstellen seit februar behoben bist du auch sehr.
Das ist das ist beruhigend wir können hoffen dass apple sich da irgendwie ein bisschen mehr mühe gibt inzwischen wird übrigens berichtet aus gut informierten kreisen,
dass in das explodiert gegen android,
inzwischen teurer gehandelt werden als explodiert gegen us,
und das ist,
ein ebenfalls beunruhigend das zeichen weil die idee ja schon ist das quasi der der preis eines explodiert wenn man sagt okay für bestimmte,
es wird sehr viel geld gebotene würde man nach marktwirtschaftlichen regeln davon ausgehen dass ein solcher expert schwer herzustellen des hohem aufwand erfordert mit anderen worten die plattform relativ sicher ist ja also wenn ich weiß,
okay ich habe ein telefon in der tasche der explodiert dafür wird für eine million gehandelt dann weiß ich dass im zweifelsfall nur menschen die eine million euro ausgeben mich als ziel haben,
oder mich als ziel haben können wenn ich weiß der,
für mein gerät kostet fünfundzwanzig euro ist das für mich eine,
beunruhigender situation außer jetzt wo ihr keine aussagen konto zu treffen kann,
der psd zwei aber.
Ich habe zum beispiel nur fünfundzwanzig euro in der tasche wer also ne und inzwischen scheint es jetzt so zu sein dass bestimmte experten sagen sie zahlen inzwischen für android mehr als für ios und das,
das ist noch nie so gewesen da muss apple sich mehr.
Könnte es nicht auch bedeuten dass die,
explodiert selber alleine nur weil sie in kombination mit vielen anderen benutzt werden müssen deswegen weniger wert sind also gibt es noch andere faktoren die auf diesen preis einen einfluss haben außer.
Also es werden sowieso immer explodiert ketten verkauft ne gerade so ein gerät kriegst du selten mit einem explodiert auf oder brauchst halt kombination aus verschiedenen,
um wirklich so ein telefon mal durchgehend zu aufzumachen weil es geht ja los wird wenn das jetzt über eine webseite geht dann brauchst du erstmal eine schwachstelle in dem browser was weiß ich safari,
meistens findet man die dann irgendwie in den pdf länder oder so dann hast du irgendwie dann bist du aber erstmal noch in der box das der farid der läuft ja in einer box auf dem iphone dann musst du irgendwie aus dieser fanbox ausbrechen und dann musst du irgendwie noch das coaching umgehen,
und das heißt du brauchst sowieso schon mal drei ganz elegante möglichkeiten um dann irgendwie auf diesem gerät zu laufen da brauchst du eigentlich noch gut,
level access wenn du dann wirklich anfangen willst andere in andere geräte in andere applikationen und sand boxers einzugreifen also es sind eh schon immer nicht nur eine schwachstelle und einiges.
Aber es könnte theoretisch bedeuten ich weil ich als iphone benutzer hoffe natürlich nicht dass es so ist aber es könnte theoretisch bedeuten,
des apple jetzt zehn jahre security bei curiosity ihnen geholfen haben die exporte preise hoch zu treiben jetzt aber inzwischen android durch open doors soweit abgehangen ist,
das jetzt auf einmal ob und obwohl android eben dieses können viele dann doch wieder kaputt machen und so weiter offene betriebssystem war was,
ja so dass das das neue windows eigentlich ist was die sicherheit angeht das neue alte windows,
könnte es jetzt sein dass hier oben auch nochmal auf lange sicht dann auf einmal doch gewinnt die explodiert preise deuten das zumindest gerade an.
Das ist aber jetzt na ja aber das ist jetzt erstmal eine pure vermutung oder also ich meine.
Auf jeden fall für android explosives mehr kohle als für experte ich glaube nicht dass das lange so bleibt.
Okay.
Weil,
einfach bei apple quasi sehr viel hardware security direkt mit in das betriebssystem eingeworfen werden kann und es deswegen,
und dass die ganzen android geräte immer nochmal vorweg haben müssen für irgendwelche grabe kisten telefone und so aber im moment ist das jetzt mal der stadt.
Was seine these ein bisschen unterstützen ist natürlich dass apple auch seine background die programme extrem angehoben hat also sie hauen jetzt dermaßen viel mehr geld als vorher raus für sachen die gefunden werden damit,
wobei damit reagieren sie ja eigentlich auf gestiegene preise also
dreht sich das jetzt wieder ein bisschen im kreis also ich meine sie müssen halt mehr bieten damit die box bei ihnen abgeliefert werden und nicht bei irgendwelchen anderen böse richtern,
das wäre ja eigentlich ein zeichen dafür dass die preise wieder steigen oder.
Also mich interessiert eigentlich nur der relative preis wenn sich das jetzt dauerhaft so wenn das dauerhaft so bleibt das äh bei android mehr mehr gezahlt wird dann ruhig,
der kommt an meine tante apps drauf.
Ach ja das ist gar nicht so einfach im internet alles richtig zu machen unsere freunde von der afd haben da ja auch so ihre probleme nachdem sie wieder ein neues äh eine tolle idee hatten dass er schon ein bisschen her ne,
und.
Ja die machen das in unterschiedlichen bundesländern glaube ich also das ist die freunde von der afd.
Genau also worum geht sie wollen halt sozusagen unsere unsere schulen von politischer schlag seite befreien ja ganz uneigennützig auch.
Wie ihr ja wisst wird in den schulen werden ja die schülerinnen und schüler,
zu bolschewiki trainiert ja das ist ja ganz schlimm links grün versifft was wir da an lehrer pack haben ja was sie den leuten da einreden.
Die demonstrieren für das klima bekommen denn da hin.
Ja ganz schlimme was hat der gauland nochmal gesagt das programm der grünen irgendwie flüchtlinge aufnehmen klimawandel.
Leuten helfen.
Leuten helfen flüchtlinge aufnehmen und klima retten das denn.
Das kann eigentlich unterstützen das geht überhaupt nicht komm mal hin nein am ende noch nett sein.
Und da endlich mal was zu tun ja dass diese bullshit christliche verschwörung in dessen klammer griff,
die bundesrepublik deutschland befindet.
Genau da sind wir dann vorangeschritten und ein schönes portal aufgesetzt und verbessern portal mit dem optimistische namen neutrale schule,
und dort sollten dann irgendwie schüler lehrer melden die gegen das politische neutralität gebot verstoßen.
Also ich sag dir eins tim ich bin ganz ehrlich.
Das ist gut ja warte ich schon lange drauf.
Nee aber ich sag dir eins ich hatte so ein paar lehrerinnen und lehrern ne.
Jetzt auch gerne für pets.
Die sind mir so auf den sack gegangen hätte ich einfach gesagt hier hat gesagt der letzte mal wieder die ganze stunde das kapital vorgelesen,
so dass der nach oben kommt ne dass die afd als erstes dort vorbei fährt ne einfach weil ich die wirklich nicht mochte aber,
wir haben das glaube ich auch schon mal im logbuch behandelt als solches portal ist natürlich der absolute absoluter irrsinn,
absoluter wahnsinn und zum glück wurde das jetzt wenigstens in mecklenburg-vorpommern,
vom daten vom landesbeauftragte für den datenschutz verboten unter zwangs geld das ist,
wirklich gut also ich meine dass wir solche dass wir solche zustände auch nur in der nähe von tolerieren dass hier irgendwelche parteien demonstrationen portale für lehrer machen,
oder für egal wen das ist wirklich so was von dermaßen daneben sowas von skandalös und deswegen bin ich sehr froh dass das geschlossen.
Argumentation die verarbeitung von daten aus denen die politische meinung hervorgeht sei laut datenschutzgrundverordnung grundsätzlich,
untersagt und nur in ausnahmefällen erlaubt.
Schön ist er hat da noch,
der herr müller hat dann noch freundlich die presse darauf hingewiesen dass jeder und die idee vom afd landesverband auskunft verlangen kann,
ob ihre person betreffende daten verarbeitet worden sind oder nicht das kann jeder tun.
Einfach mal hinschreiben.
Du das.
Irgendwas über mich.
Das ist äh das kann jetzt wirklich jede tun und das erinnert mich übrigens an einen artikel auf netz politik ort den ich geschrieben habe.
Damals als praktikant.
Der wetter der hieß den,
da ging es darum warte der hieß den springer verlag zurück trollen und zwar war das da hatten die irgendwie geburtstag mit ihrer bild-zeitung,
zweitausendzwölf zwar zwanzigster juni zweitausendzwölf habe ich einen artikel auf netzwerk geschrieben,
und zwar haben sie da gesagt sie stecken jetzt jedem zum geburtstag ihrer blöden bild-zeitung eine bildzeitung in den.
Die nummer ja ja.
Und äh wollte also am dreiundzwanzigsten juni wollte der springer-verlag alle haushalte in deutschland mit einer gratis bildzeitung versorgen.
Hast du stumm gemacht ne.
Und dann habe ich habe ich dann wurde bekannt wie sie das wenn man gesagt hat man konnte den schreiben ich will eure zeitungen nicht haben,
ich möchte das nicht ja und dann haben sie gesagt dass sie um das quasi zu,
also um sicherzustellen dass die leute die keine,
wollen die auch nicht kriegen haben sie all diesen leuten,
eine adressiert großformatigen infopoint post sendung in einem auffälligen roten umschlag zukommen lassen,
das diente den zweck diese bildzeitung wurde nämlich von den brief trainerinnen und rief trägern,
und die hatten dann quasi die anweisung erst verteilt sie die roten umschläge dann weißt du bei wem du keine bild reintun darfst und dann tust du da keine bild rein ne das war quasi so dass der user interface für die für die post zusteller,
und äh da habe ich natürlich widersprochen dass ich einen roten umschlag von ihnen bekomme.
Und,
ja moment das geht ja noch wer soll ja noch besser da habe ich gesagt ich zitiere aus dem artikel um eine eingehende bearbeitung meines schreibens sicherzustellen versagt erschreiben außerdem mit allen forderungen die des bundes datenschutzgesetz hergibt,
nämlich den forderungen über welche daten speichern sie über mich und so weiter weil wir einen roten briefumschlag zuzustellen haben die offenbar meine persönlichen daten gespeichert also habe ich sofortige löschung dieser daten bestätigung der löschung der daten und so weiter von denen verlangt,
und das heißt sie müssen jetzt löschen dass ich dass sie mich gespeichert hatten wir ein,
äh briefumschlag zu schicken dann habe ich das an mehrere briefe an mehrere e-mail-adressen geschrieben,
und hab dann diese schreiben nur zur sicherheit nochmal auf netzwerk geblockt,
und das führte dann dazu dass offenbar noch ein paar andere leute das gemacht haben und wenige stunden später wurde unter dem artikel kommentiert,
der messe aber keine e-mails.
Von spiel springer.
Und dann haben sie glaube ich versucht gegen also wollten sie mich anzeigen wegen einer mail bombe weil ich ihn emails übernahm gelegt,
mit der aktion dann hab ich dann hab ich aber keine auskunft bekommen über die löschung meine daten dann habe ich die band berliner daten,
und dann haben wir ein aufsicht verfahren vom berliner datenschutz bekommen dass nur also die erzähl ich jetzt völlig am rande nur ne dass dass es bei dem springer-verlag damals,
also bitte nicht jetzt einfach bei der afd mecklenburg-vorpommern anfragen ob die daten über euch.
Man stellt euch mal vor es würde jetzt alle alle machen ja.
Ne das ist schlimm also es war ganz schlimm für den springer verlag.
Die ja gar nichts gar nichts.
Ja der hätten.
Komm her mit ihrer ganzen hetzerei gar nicht mehr hinterher.
Stimmt dann könnt ihr nicht mehr hetzen also.
Ist es ne.
Und das war auf jeden fall damals ganz witzig ich hab dann den roten briefumschlag bekommen,
den habe ich dem dem dem berliner datenschutz geschickt und hab gesagt hier die haben hier post geschickt obwohl die gesagt haben sie hätten wir daten gelöscht,
ah das waren noch zeiten.
Das waren noch zeiten ja.
Das waren die zeiten da saßen wir noch mit zwei leuten in diesem büro.
Man hatte zeit für alles.
Für sowas hatten wir zeit aber sowas sowas hab ich auch heute noch zeit bin ich ganz ehrlich ja.
Ja man stellt sich immer nur vor du hättest so viel zeit gehabt dass er einfach durch deine stadt wann das und die schönen dinge des lebens konsumierst und deine erinnerung aufbaust auch mal was fotografierst was dir gefällt,
weil alles immer irgendjemand gleich gehört,
wie in hamburg da gehört und hast 'n hafen fotografiert was.
Nein nein das weiß man doch dass wir den hafen in hamburg nicht fotografieren.
Woher weiß man das warum weil er blau markiert ist oder was.
Mir das wusste ich nicht ja das hätte ich auch nicht vorstellen.
Es gibt da eine lichtinstallation oder gab und es läuft noch bis zum fünfzehnten september was haben wir heute ach ja den dreizehnten hatten wir ja schon genau,
da leuchtet irgendwie diverses auf blau,
mystisches licht und äh das lädt natürlich dazu ein dass man fotografiert und man würde sich ja auch fragen warum sollte man jetzt den hafen,
beleuchten das schön machen und dann damit rechnen dass es niemand fotografiert auf jeden fall haben das dann.
Genau damit gerechnet dass es jemand fotografiert.
Ja
Weil sie haben ja auch sofort die abmahnungen verschickt wenn wir uns auf instagram gepostet.
Ja das ist echt geil also irgendjemand hat das auf instagram veröffentlicht das überrascht natürlich jetzt herzlich wenig und da wurde es eben gleich wegen urheberrecht an diesem bild,
wir hatten vor wann war das das waren neunzehnhundert siebenundneunzig,
gab's ja in berlin diese schöne installation des verhüten reichstags.
Äh habe ich auf bildern gesehen ich fand das doof.
Bilder du kannst es doof ich fand es hervorragend ich fand es eine der schönsten aktion,
überhaupt also ich bin ganz großer freund davon überhaupt generell von dem was christopher macht aber ich fand insbesondere diese diese reichstags aktion total irre einfach,
wenn man davor saß hatte sie hatte das wirklich eine strahlte haben halt das muss man erstmal hinkriegen
und aber auch da war es ja so dass dieses kunst,
den staat nichts kostete also es muss ja quasi nur der reichstag
bereitgestellt werden dass man da ihnen eben verhüllt was er dann getan wurde auch wenn sich die politiker jahrelang dagegen gewehrt haben weil wo kommen denn da hin und überhaupt in unser schöner reichstag um kann jeder kommen wo er dann aber gott sei dank alles überstimmt,
trotz alledem war natürlich dann auch das problem dass es natürlich dann auch wiederum von leuten fotografiert wurden und die auflage war natürlich das,
über das urheberrecht abgesichert die ganzen fotos davon dass der verkauf davon natürlich christoph,
zugute kommen sollte einfach um diese kosten auch wieder zu stemmen und generell natürlich,
den einnahmen zu generieren.
Die die einnahmen kam nicht im deutschen volk.
Weil das hier oben dran steht aber deswegen war das ja auch verhüllt.
Achso dem deutschen volk ja.
Der hamburger hafen ist nicht der reichstag.
Der hamburger hafen wenn er beleuchtet.
Und der wurde auch nicht verhüllt der wurde blau beleuchtet.
Ja ist aber jetzt ist aber jetzt rein technisch nichts anderes nur natürlich das,
auf instagram ist jetzt nicht unbedingt dasselbe wie das verkaufen von foto drucken
kann man natürlich lange darüber diskutieren was ist wenn die influencer kommen und so ist auf jeden fall schwierig und,
wir haben da einfach auch,
ein problem haben wir sowieso schon mit dieser panorama freiheit was dazu fotografieren weil wir haben ja auch das problem dass ihr im prinzip jedes gebäude auch urheberrechte geschützt ist,
und das fotografieren davon schwierig ist meine ich hatte ja mein ähnlichen fall als wir dieses blinkt 's gemacht und war im prinzip genau das gleiche werden wir auch irgendwie öffentliches gut beleuchtet und,
da konnte das jeder fotografieren man stellt euch das mal vor also natürlich dann kein,
verklagt und verfolgt so aber schon generell so eine so eine debatte und manchmal kann ich die zwänge von künstlern auch verstehen.
Also hier gab es ihr ganz noch noch ein weiteres problem dass man erwähnen muss und zwar behalten sich facebook und instagram,
bestimmte rechte vor wenn ihr bilder dort hochladet also in dem moment gehören die den teilweise haben
teile der verwertung rechte und das ist dann wiederum 'ne kommerzielle nutzung durch facebook instagram und deswegen hat er gesagt so einmal die künstler dann gesagt so ein moment kommerzielle nutzung ist aber ausgeschlossen,
und wer das aber wenn jemand kommerziell dass irgendwie nutzt dann muss er das immer noch bei uns wie zensieren,
das war so 'n bisschen der konflikt pfeife die auch aber ich frage mich ernsthaft wenn du eine kunstaktion machst,
und dann sagst du irgendwie der presse naja ihr seid aber kommerziell im zweifelsfall,
und ihr dürft meine meine aktion hier nicht fotografieren da musst du dich halt auch nicht wundern wenn du nicht auf instagram bist mit deiner.
Eine wunder muss man sich da nicht auf der anderen seite sind natürlich diese ganzen,
einschränken rechts vorschriften zu denen man,
sich auf die man sich dann einlässt wenn man an solchen plattformen teilnimmt auch problematisch weil die halt einfach bei die voll sagen so ja ja alles unseres ein bisschen also wir dürfen jetzt zumindest,
meine wesentlichen sind ja diese rechts formulierung alles immer positiv beleuchten möchte die versuchen sich quasi aus
aus hessel rauszuhalten im wesentlichen ist dieses,
ist ja für sie eine absicherung dass sie dafür wiederum nicht verklagt werden jetzt trifft es natürlich die nutzer die dann darauf eingewilligt haben deswegen ist ein schwieriges feld da müssen wir irgendwann mal mit julia räder nochmal drüber diskutieren glaube ich,
der da bestimmt tolle meinung.
Panorama freiheit alles.
Panorama alles frei.
So dann sind wir beim nächsten thema ich habe ein buch,
gar nicht meinen da wunderbar an sich wo ich noch zeit zu haben hab ich mich auch.
Wie lang wie groß wie viel seiten viele weniger.
Wenige zu wenige wie das immer so ist ne.
Weniger du durftest nicht mehr oder du konntest nicht mehr.
Bitte entschuldigen sie der sich so einen langen text geschrieben habe ich hatte keine zeit nicht kurz zu fassen das gleiche problem hatte ich mit dem kapitel ich hatte keine zeit nicht,
zu fassen aber ich habe einen das buch heißt wann wenn nicht,
mit einem sternchen einem wir und das ist der rat revolution s ratgeber von extension.
Und rebellion ist eine britische bewegung die sich zum ziel gesetzt hat mit methoden des zivilen ungehorsam gegen den klimawandel vorzugehen und die politik zum handeln zu zwingen,
und dem gilt natürlich meine sympathie und die haben sich da,
erst vor kurzer zeit also vor wenigen etwas über einem jahr oder so,
eben in großbritannien gegründet und machen da jetzt ihr machen da jetzt ihr ding und das wird jetzt in deutschland eben auch gestartet mit dem klima streik am zwanzigsten neunten,
und ja und dann habe ich da so ein bisschen dazu geschrieben wenn man.
Wenn man also beabsichtigt sich im zivilen ungehorsam und politisch zu vernetzen und mit fremden und große bewegungen zu machen dass es da ein paar,
sinnvolle vorsichtsmaßnahmen gibt die habe ich da,
zumindest teilweise teilweise erläutert wie das so ist,
ein bisschen vielleicht dazu zu helfen dabei zu helfen dass diese,
sehr schnell wachsende bewegung nicht irgendwie an sich selber scheitert wie halt viele andere nach allen seiten offenen,
bewegung es tun und da wurde ursprünglich mal ein kapitel noch so von einigen der lektorin so als ein bisschen aluhut mäßig,
abgetan also gesagt so ja hör mal das ist ja was was denkst du denn was hier los ist aber jetzt wurde gerade der mitbegründer in london also der mitbegründer von berlin,
roger,
wurde direkt verhaftet und jetzt fühle ich mich klug dass ich ein paar tipps,
wenigstens im deutschen buch beigesteuert habe wollte ich erzählen und am zwanzigsten neunten ist klima.
Wird es auch noch auf.
Der fliege ich glaube ich auch dann.
Bist du das glas natürlich.
Klar also sonst einfach zu eng in so ein flugzeug ne,
äh klima streik am zwanzigsten neunten buch gibt's ich habe das das geblockt,
ich habe sogar vorher den verlag gefragt darf ich durfte ich und ähm das buch gibt es glaube ich auch hier also einige der mit autorinnen sind auch hier und hier waren ja heute auch immer mehrere,
klima geschichten und lesungen und so da sind,
die herausgeberin einen dabei und so ich muss jetzt gerade mal gucken wer denn die herausgeberin sieht das im fischer verlag erschienen,
finden wir gar nicht meinen dass dass ich nochmal in fischer verlag erscheinen würde sina kamera kaufmann die ist auf jeden fall hier michael zimmermann und annemarie bot ski sind die,
herausgeberin dieses buches das heißt wann wenn nicht wir ein extension rebellion handbuch was ist pink und es gibt auch als,
als e-book privat kopie könnte ich sogar haben vielleicht.
Ja gut kannst ruhig mal sagen dass ich das gut war dass ich was geschrieben habe.
Ja natürlich ist das gut also man muss vielleicht mal ein bisschen was über extension rebellieren sagen weil das ist so im letzten jahr oder schon ein bisschen früher aufgehört
poppt und ist so quasi die etwas wieder spenden sichere variante des.
Also spiegel hat das.
Gegen den klimawandel.
Als greta bergs radikale geschwister die denn so in dem buch wird so erklärt wie man zum beispiel eine brücke block oder so,
und also blockaden sind jetzt irgendwie das thema ich glaube für morgen deswegen wurde auch der oder war das heute.
Sie wollten hier jetzt lahmlegen mit drohnen,
genau und er hat auch persönlich angekündigt dass daran teilnehmen wollte wobei das jetzt nicht bedeutet dass die drohnen so hoch fliegen lassen dass da wirklich 'ne gefährdung von ausgeht sondern sie wollen sich sozusagen nur drumherum platzieren mit ganz viel drohen die so ein bisschen irgendwie auf kopfhöhe rumschwirren lassen aber das hat schon.
Und dann selber die bullen rufen und sagen der flughafen ist unser.
Genau so und das ist natürlich ganz tricky aber in großbritannien.
Mein mein mein flug am zwanzigsten noch umbuchen bevor die,
aber in der business class.
Ja auf jeden fall haben sie da wenig humor derzeit in großbritannien das ist ja ohnehin gerade das problem dass sie da relativ wenig humor haben sind alle.
Die haben auch wenig zu lachen wenn man sich das land angucken.
Sonst aber sonst hat das ja immer zu viel humor geführt so ne also umso schwieriger die zeiten umso besser der humor das ist derzeit nicht so richtig festzustellen
tatsache ist dass glaube ich auch von extension rebellen 'ne gewisse,
auch auszugehen scheint die wieder alle so ein bisschen in so einem,
sind das jetzt terroristen oder was modus bringen und das zeigt natürlich so eine,
so eine festnahme die natürlich letzten endes dieser bewegung wunderbar in die karten spielt weil ich könnte mir vorstellen dass das jetzt erst richtig los.
Ja also nach über fliege ich dann nicht,
so dann haben wir vier hundertneunzehn millionen telefonnummern hast du schon mal eine angerufen.
Hast du dich schon geschickt.
Ne das ist doch ein bisschen zu übertragen.
Na ja gut.
Hat er hat facebook verloren.
Echt wo denn.
Ja waren für einige zeit offen im netz abrufbar,
ja im internet und das waren irgendwie telefonnummer die sie benutzt haben um dieses,
finde meine freunde oder so dazu abzusetzen und dann waren die halt frei zugreift bei hat irgendjemand geschraubt und dann veröffentlicht
hundertneunzehn personen betroffen einige aber doppelt primär usa großbritannien und vietnam.
Hundertneunzehn millionen ja.
Vierhundertsechzehn millionen ja er ist mehr als.
Als tarnung man gibt.
So äh sechs ja ja das ist sehr viel mehr als das tattoo mann gibt vielleicht sollten die dir einfach als tattoo annehmen.
Ja geben sie die dreihundert vierundachtzig millionen sechshundert dreiundvierzigtausend neunundzwanzigste telefonnummer ein die sie jetzt gerade bei facebook heruntergeladen haben dann dürfen sie die ersten zehn zeilen ihres kontoauszug s lesen.
Es ist natürlich eine schlechte nachricht ja für die vierhundert neunzehn millionen betroffenen menschen aus die primär aus den usa großbritannien und vietnam stammen also,
man könnte jetzt sagen breitere ne also wenn 's nur gurken gewesen wäre es auch nicht für hundertneunzehn millionen.
Was sagst du ja.
Und großbritannien ist ja noch in der europäischen union,
deswegen greift er jetzt natürlich die europäische datenschutz-grundverordnung und da könnt ihr das jetzt für facebook nochmal teuer werden das bin ich mal gespannt wie das wie das weiter.
Deswegen wollt ihr austreten das nicht so teuer wird oh mann.
Dann haben wir noch ein thema das haben wir ausgelassen dass da geht's um staatsstraße jana aber das da muss ich euch vertrösten auf nächste oder übernächste sendung weil da könnte das das könnte noch mal sehen,
cliffhänger,
wir müssen auch mit solchen tricks arbeiten hast kein internet mehr oder.
Ne jetzt weiß ich grad nicht was du jetzt überspringen willst.
Ach so das kann ich ja auch so soll ich noch erzählen ja zeit haben wir wir haben noch zeit ja.
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt zeit haben wir noch auf jeden fall ein bisschen noch.
Also ich habe einen ich habe einen vortrag gehalten und zwar bei der schwarz kopf stiftung über das internet und die demokratie.
Sind das die mit dem shampoo.
Das will ich schon mal gefahren ich weiß es nicht die heißen junges europa aber wahrscheinlich schon ich gucke mal ganz kurz.
Das ist ja auch eine form von schleichwerbung mach weiter ist nicht so wichtig.
Ja ich gucke ich gucke jetzt wenn du mich was fragst bei uns bleibt keine frage um beantworte.
Komm komm komm komm komm ja der hat ich weiß sonst ja ja sonst ignorierst du meine fragen immer aber so ein quatsch darauf gehst du ein ja.
Also die gibt es das ist eine stiftung und die haben sich irgendwie verwalten ihr von heinz schwarz kommen,
neunzehnhunderteinundsiebzig in gedenken an heinz schwarz,
dem sohn des haar kosmetik industriellen,
aus metro industrielle hallo was machst du denn so.
Das ist im bereich der kosmetik unterwegs.
Ich bin ich bin sekretär naja ich,
kosmetik industrielle ja ich meine wer kann das schon von sich behaupten,
jedenfalls genau bei dieser stiftung die sich irgendwie für europa und demokratie und so weiter interessieren,
da habe ich für schülerinnen und schüler einen vortrag gehalten mit dem das internet und seine auswirkungen auf die demokratie das war sehr interessant weil,
also der mein vortrag ohnehin klar aber die die nachfolgende diskussion war sehr interessant,
ich habe eine aufzeichnung davon online gestellt und.
Einschließlich der diskussion.
Ja einschließlich der.
Wie alt war neben schüler.
Die schüler waren ich würde sagen,
sie waren größtenteils unter achtzehn aber ich sag mal von denen kam auch.
Wie die meisten schüler.
Kam auch die von mir gewürdigt den diskussionsbeiträge es gab zwei diskussionsbeiträge von leuten die erwachsenen waren,
komm.
Das cliffhänger auf.
Es war es war sehr es war sehr interessant und ich fand das ganz gut ich glaube ich hatte jetzt öfter wieder vorträge vor schülerinnen und,
aufkleber gibt's haben wir hier noch stehen wo sind die aufkleber.
Im beutelchen die hole ich dann gleich raus wenn wenn ihr.
Tim verteilt gleich aufkleber.
Ja viele haben wir nicht mehr die meisten sind schon auf dem camp weggegangen.
Hier dürft ihr die glaube ich nicht ankleben weil das ist alles hier.
Schlechte idee immer nur auf dem laptop draufkleben.
Immer nur auf dem laptop und auch bitte diese ein herz für aufkleber ne nicht auf kleben ne dürfte nicht machen.
Das ist ganz schlechte idee so dann sind wir soweit oder machen wir das ja ich brauche die termin musik.
Was hat der termin mehr sieht.
Ok gut mache ich.
Aux
Am zwanzigsten september ist ja der wahrscheinlich weltweite aber,
mindestens deutschlandweit der klima streik darauf folgende eine aktionswoche vom zwanzigsten bis siebenundzwanzigsten september,
da gibt's dieses global ja also globale aktionswoche und da könnt ihr euch sicherlich in jeder stadt informieren welche aktion ist da so gibt um euch zu,
das macht spaß.
Und in der nächsten woche konkrete am einundzwanzigsten und zweiundzwanzigsten september in,
dresden aber ich glaube es ist auch schon am freitag gibt 's auch schon aktivitäten ach so das ist ja der zwanzigste ist ja sogar der freitag stimmt
ach so ist es nicht am sonntag war das nicht mal so egal ich bin komplett raus auf jeden fall unter dem schönen titel,
gehabt gibt's die daten spuren in dresden und da könnt ihr alle noch hinfahren und da geht's dann weiter mit all dem ganzen netz politischen gedöns und anderen interessanten vorträgen,
ich glaube die haben sogar podcasts.
Und der mittig der hacker space deutschlands,
treibt nun seit zehn jahren durchs all das ist wie wir alle wissen der flip dort in kassel und der feiert jetzt sein zehnjähriges bestehen mit einer momenta,
vom dritten bis sechsten oktober zweitausendneunzehn ja das ist das lange wochenende zum tag der deutschen einheit,
und da gibt's vorträge workshops basteln uns und das wird auf jeden fall chaos in kassel.
Momenta ist schön.
Hey kilometer steigt man dann in kassel wilhelms.
Das muss man immer weil.
Eine eine auch ein architektonische gedicht dieser ein architektonische gedicht dieser bahnhof sieht aus wie ein flughafen.
Naja das ist ja auch so dass was.
Der hat das feng shui von der a vierzig in essen.
Bei der bahnhof am frankfurter flughafen sieht aus wie flughafen.
Da ist aber wenigstens einer.
Stimmt.
Damit wären wir beim beim dank angekommen und ich danke an dieser stelle einfach mal wie ihr wisst habe ich keinen zugang zu meinem vermögen.
Abgeschnitten.
Ja wahrscheinlich sagt die bank sich für drei euro achtzig wissen sie was hier die minute kostet wenn sie mir telefonieren ich danke deshalb heute einfach mal nur,
den markus becker dafür dass er vor fünfzehn jahren die idee hatte anzufangen zu bloggen das ding jetzt irgendwie hochgezogen hat auf eine der bedeutendsten unabhängigen medien plattformen deutschlands,
und wenn ich ehrlich sein soll,
haben wir alle oder ich zumindest bei euch weiß ich nicht markus dann auch logbuch netz politik zu verdanken denn so haben dann auch irgendwann tim und ich zueinander gefunden diesen podcast zu machen,
und damit hat markus mit diesem spatenstich einfach was ganz großartiges in die wege geleitet heute ein riesiges team ich glaube was das sechzehn leute auf zwölf stellen oder wie das war,
alles rot diamanten und brillanten des interviews investigative journalismus und der politischen aufklärung und dafür einfach an dieser stelle nochmal wirklich herzlichen dank.
Genau,
so und uns bleibt uns dann auch äh eigentlich nur noch zu danken fürs kommen und für's zuhören hier bei logbuch netz politik live,
und überhaupt so wissen wir euch immer in unserem rücken und das macht auch eine ganze menge rückenwind macht immer noch spaß und ich hoffe ihr bleibt auch dabei wir bleiben auf jeden fall noch dabei für heute war's das jetzt erstmal also,
vielen dank fürs kommen.